getting it's lovely to see you here at
learning film comic-con it's been very
busy for you guys today you got Finn
here as well has it been going yeah it's
been a fantastic day really we've had a
lot of fun you know it's always fun with
Finn and it's a really big fantastic
shows the Beast when I've been to the UK
I think sorry's wise you know it's all
as ever though you know incredible
costumes people there's a guy over there
just Batman looks pretty fantastic and
you know that really adds to the fun of
the days just for us to get to see what
fans put into their you know cosplay and
costumes and stuff like that so yeah
it's been a busy old season on Game of
Thrones and Loras has had his eye on
Oberyn Martell has he not only a little
flirtation what did he make with that of
his ex well uh when Oberon turned up
this is here isn't slack ah right so
he's taking I mean he was played so
fantastic by bedro I was I was really
rooting for there to be some kind of
story and I'm with Loras because or just
you know just I just really enjoyed
watching him he seems and and I thought
it was really fun though they've got
something in there with with Loras it's
kind of a shame we won't see any more of
Oberyn in the future spoiler alert
what did you think when you saw the
episode when you saw that fight between
Gregor Clegane mounted and the Viper
yeah I've been I've been avoiding I mean
I you know I read part you know three
first three books but for the last
couple of years I've been kind of
watching the series and staying away
from that like you know not talking to
guys about what's gonna happen cuz I'm
you know I'm a huge fan of the show now
so I didn't know what was gonna happen
and I honestly thought the Oberon was
going to turn and belt his weapon at
Tywin I really thought that I was gonna
happen and then it didn't um bhavish
tyrant as well I mean what an incredible
end but yeah so there I yeah I just
watched it like everybody else and this
is kind of gobsmacked
when you saw those eyes popping yeah I
mean they're you know it's a it actually
that that was that was an incredible
shot like I don't know what that I would
imagine there were several technical
elements that I mean when Renly's death
happened like I got to see just how many
people involved in creating those
moments and that was and actually what I
was watching I was thinking like which
department so whether it be makeup or
visual effects and that which layer they
come in it's fascinating to get to see
behind the scenes of all that
wonderfully done they'd used to do these
artists add videos on the DVDs I wonder
if they've used that as a moment to do I
hope they do except that would be a
really interesting thing to see how they
pulled it off you know the you mentioned
also Tywin's death which is pretty
interesting wasn't a what do you make
when you saw that um well again I was
really shocked because I didn't know is
coming oh yeah I mean I guess it's just
beautifully marked you know beautifully
carried off I like they do killing well
those boys don't they okay what they do
killing well who does killing more Jamie
throws lives yeah they do I see they do
it really well ladies yeah some of the
deficit season I love the death with the
oh the giant honey and he he does the
arrow pings the arrow in its hits the
guiding all the way over amazing I think
that was one of the most expensive
deaths ever Game of Thrones I really
that's why I heard that I might as we
make it up all the facts from Finn all
the facts from faint owns I'm gonna
start your television show sorry this is
this is this is getting's interview I'm
and Broncos fine alright so what we're
wearing off on the question is what do
you guys what are you guys talking about
what's on the agenda we're about to get
in and you can check in as well about
the purple wedding specifically the
scene were they have the five dwarf King
did at the War of the five kings and
their dwarves and they had been named
and they had Alaura surrender what do
you make her I thought that I mean I
thought the
the gentleman who played that scene did
it with a huge amount of courage as did
all that is in it and Pete Peter did an
incredible job in that scene like I mean
it was it's a hurtful vicious kind of
story to tell and and something that you
kind of think that that will have
happened in European courts yeah and the
way we did it was the director before it
none of us knew what was going to happen
and he was like okay right I don't me
tell you what happens and just act
naturally to it and it came out and I
all of us were just like what the what
the [ __ ] is this like this is this is
the GOP is there and and then I see this
guy like obviously dressed as a stand
and bombing her to death it was like it
was really intense but brilliant TV
though really really clever really fun
yeah it's an extraordinary shocking
scene and then I thought but again it's
like a a difficult storytelling I
thought they talked to told it very well
really that's a great moment of course
the purple wedding but what were your
other top kind of season four moments
meeting overran when he what when he
rocks up who's this guy
yeah he's a peach fantastic um what
about oh oh oh no Rory McCann and
towards yet all that something in I mean
the and and obviously amazing as well
know those scenes and you know I really
thought we did some incredible work but
he has two out but those scenes were
beautiful and dark and horrible you know
like I heard leaving him Alice both um
just played played Gwen at the end
my lover when they just bash each other
in the genitals like that she's like BAM
right knees knives knees alright [ __ ]
you both right in the minge mins
that's a horrible word I'm sorry I
should never use that word gross yeah
what else you cool what do you bop-bop
my fanny ryan fanny I don't know what
the name hey guys I'm Emily that's my
work I'll leave you to it give me help
I'm just next to you really need Oh
straining yeah sure great got it
brilliant hey guys now there's been a
lot of WTF moments in the show the whole
way through not just a season happening
if you had to pick your kind of top ones
and made an impression that still kind
of spring back to your mind what would
they be there are so many I see how Robb
Stark's who are the red wedding like how
that went down but it specifically you
know what happened to in a chapters
character the way she was killed and and
and catched up as well just how that was
executed literally it was it left me
left me kind of shuddering and I I knew
what was coming you know and finally if
you could have anything happen for Laura
going forward what would you like to
have happen your former love Oh what
would I like I'd like him to take up
religion and become celibate
and and and build a shrine in Highgarden
to rent it no visits what would I like
to see happens your character alright
okay well what do you want to see
average over here I've worked this out
today actually I want to see it so that
missing dragon I want to see brand warp
the missing dragon get over his way to
King's Landing like we saw in his
premonition when you touch the tree and
then I want Loras to somehow tame the
dragon like a bee like a horse tamer but
I can dragon tamer and then ride the
dragon like into battle get Stannis and
like ah I like [ __ ] Stannis's army off
and then ride off into the sunset end of
Game of Thrones
doesn't oh yeah so George if you're
listening that is now you're ending
that's what's happening George get with
the program
you